well good after afternoon everyone um in
the chamber and at home and welcome to
this first meeting in the chamber in
2024 and being the first meeting I would
just like to wish everybody a Happy New
Year um those of you at home and those
of you in the chamber Happy New Year I I
promise that's the last time I'll say
this in here I won't say every meeting
for the next couple of months um
apologies uh we have an apology from M
Clark who I'm certain will be watching
this on live stream um we have an
apology for councelor Arnold who is
actually not on this committee is he
so um we have uh an apology for
counselor K and I think it' be
appropriate I'm sure counselors would
wish me to offer condolences to
counselor care for the loss of bery a
week
ago um and we should have Daren on
Zoom but we don't be joining us
momentarily okay so d llo uh who
normally cheers this committee uh will
join us on zoom and because it's
impossible to cheer a committee on Zoom
um I'm going to do it today
so uh Declarations of interest do we
have
any I'm Sor receive the apology correct
someone move that we receive the
apologies okay thanks Grant and
Evelyn uh those in favor say I I against
carried Declarations of interest does
anyone have any interest that they wish
to declare in the the
agenda
okay um T us to public forum and we have
Rodney trip here today who's um
going to talk to us I think about Queens
Park um welcome
Rodney General reserve the reserve
policy Y and you know how this works Ry
you've got 10 minutes which you can
either fill with 10 minutes of talking
or you can speak for five and we'll ask
questions for five or it's your choice
oh good is this working
y but well many thanks for uh your time
today um obviously uh I did subm B on
the uh General
reserves sorry what do we want to call
it general policies reserves management
plan whether it's a policy document or
reserves management plan I do not know
but I did uh I did submit on it and say
please keep our go park as it is
um under its own management plan
so having had a couple of back and
forths with Council I thought I'd turn
up today just to sort of clear the air a
bit
so in terms of the plan itself reading
through it I don't know what are
reserves what aren't reserves what are
playgrounds that are reserves and aren't
reserves um so I don't think you've been
very clear and outlining what reserves
are actually covered there's no Maps no
plans yet every other Council document
has maps and plans even the old ones had
maps and plans um
and when I look at how would I put
it there's actually papers out there
that say what counts or what an
administrating body should be uh
covering when they put a plan out and it
says reserves covered by the plan and
their boundaries must be sufficiently
described for a member of the public to
recognize them individually also says
the plan must provide details of the
classification of each Reserve other
Council documents do this one doesn't
yeah right there is nothing but it has
playgrounds which are
reserves it calls things reserves which
aren't reserves JG W is a prime
example so yeah confuses me but back
onto Aro Park I did raise the concern
that
removal um of Aro Parks own management
plan sort of grays the waters a bit so
the Aro Park management plan obviously
it has objectives in
it um one of those objectives is to
allow for the provision and operation of
a camping ground in
Bluff
right under this new proposed one it
says camping is only allowed in
campgrounds onor
Reserve I do know the council have
discussed potentially getting rid of the
campground because it's non-strategic
but also includes a children's
playground on that
section um but more than that when I
read
through the Aro Park's current one says
any tenanted buildings that be
maintained to a presentable standard of
high quality for visitors to see and
that's right on the entrance to Bluff
well on the way around the point the new
document removes that statement from
anything
but then I get back into the lease now I
know officers put a comment on my
submission that the long-term lease will
transfer if that property is ever sold
I've challenged that with Council saying
well how can that be it's
Reserve to reserve
lease and therefore if it loses Reserve
status how does that continue I have
been told well there's nothing to lease
it refers to reserves act but occupation
Agreements are covered in the management
plans which talks about the reserves
so it either is or it isn't and I don't
see how you can lease a
reserve unless it's under the
reserve but so to me I would rather you
maintain our gold parks management plan
manage it under
it and if you want to revoke that status
we'll have that discussion later on too
um but I'll get back to some of those
others in terms of JG Ward Reserve it's
not a reserve
part of it is part of its endowment land
back in October
21 Council put a paper sorry officers
put a paper to the bluff community board
about selling silwer Street and part of
that Reserve which is what we call the
ditch and Bluff beside the
playground um and that paper talks about
it not being a reserve of being
endowment land it also suggested to the
bluff community board that the s that
ditch 36 Silver Street could be used to
upgrade the bluff playground on G Street
which is basically no longer a
playground it's a bit of
dirt and
reclassify the rest of the land to an
actual
Reserve now having read some other
Council papers officers are proposing
that Council sell a lot of it so I'm
looking to get
going as part of it going to become a
reserve because the bluff community
board say no go away until you've talked
to the community has this Council
actually spoken with the bluff Comm
community board I seen nothing in any of
these from them so it's all I have to
say seven
minutes thanks Rodney as all was a very
well researched piece of work so thanks
for those comments could I I mean we'll
take questions could I could I ask you
um you made a lot of points there do you
want to summarize in a sentence what
asking Council to do yep what I'm asking
Council to do is put a line through AR
Park on that back page but I'm also
asking Council actually put some maps in
this plan because Community engagement
in inval is poor it's
lacking um but when you look at the some
of the documentation going out there for
consultation someone would look at that
back page and go oh we got a playground
here that's going to C be covered under
this but it's actually a reserve or we
got a playground that's not a reserve
how do you know what is and isn't a
reserve okay so okay understood um
questions for Rodney yes uh
Leslie thanks Mr chair um Rodney I'm
looking at appendex one which lists
162 playgrounds and parks and reserves
and the Y Hopi Sports Association and
vious
other so it's that list you agree is
comprehensive but you would like the
Mets to go with it but that list doesn't
tell me what are and aren't reserves
like the Iron Street playground is
actually a reserve it's not a playground
there is a playground on a reserve so
it's actually got Reserve status there
are some other playgrounds that are on
land that don't have Reserve status so
under the reserves act there are things
that can and can't happen on on that
land so you would like more definition
in that list that six page list that's
what some of the guidance says is to uh
plan must provide details of the
classification of each reserve your
neighborhood park strategy actually does
that but some of this actually overrides
that well that becomes obsolete so in
order for anyone to know they actually
have to go back through every single
management plan that's currently in
place confus to actually try and work it
out and who apart from me is going to
sit there and dredge through that to get
that information
Point okay thanks for that thanks Grant
yeah thanks chair thanks Brodney good to
see you here again I did see you looking
around the car park and thought what's
coming um so no good look I agree um
around your point around the clarity
with which we present information to
public particularly the the point you
made around maps and equally I think
what the point you're making is you know
we've got to make policy and that as
simple as we can for the lay person
because it's their policy so I think
they are two wellmade points and in
respect to AR gold Park um I like my
view and I'm on the bluff community
board um is the council rep um you know
it's a very strategic asset for that
community
but not according to papers that come to
count yeah I agree yeah so so but where
I think it's important is if we if we
say it's a strategic asset in terms of
what it could be then how can we um or
can we under the current ownership model
for want a better term or as a
reserve get the investment or make the
investment that's needed to really turn
it into a very strategic asset for the
the community so you know I think um in
my mind maybe a transition of ownership
that would still remain Community
ownership but in a different way that's
not in a reserve and allow investment
into it um would really make a great
asset for that community so I'd be
interested to understand if you think
there's a way
through moving it out a Reserve Land but
still retaining it in community ESS in
but in a way and shape of ownership that
can enable investment into it to then
make it a really really strong strategic
asset for that Community around camping
and you know keeping bed nights
effectively and and Bluff which then
leads to spend and those gr Grant could
I suggest cuz Rodney is going to respond
it's a big question and I suspect it
requires a big answer so maybe you guys
can take it offline and talk about it
because okay um bu you a question yeah I
just um thanks for coming along um as
far as our go park goes um I would like
to see it that we could put Camp camper
vans on there because there's nowhere in
Bluff can put Camp there already in the
campground yeah there's a camping ground
there but there's all that spare
space opportunity
to there is a section on the other side
which is
P can you use your
mic sorry just in response to um canor
Stewart um there is a a piece of land
that sits at the end of the camping
ground which is off tone Street which
you know could be developed but I can
understand and thank you for coming
Rodney in regards to augle park because
it is a significant piece of land that
Community
value and I know the medical center
value the piece that you're talking
about because I wouldn't want to
rebuilding yeah but if there was an
extension there is other Alternatives
rather than taking out the that's right
yeah okay thank you Evelyn have you got
a
question yes I also appreciate the um
the voice that speaks up for AAR pack
because it's something very dear to my
hat as well but
um I think I'm more concerned that we
shouldn't get too um down in the Weeds
about whether a park can be res a
reserve or a playground or whatever
because in policies it actually says
each Reser Reserve shall be assigned to
an appropriate Park management category
so this is a general policy I take your
point Rodney that it's not always easy
to identify which ones are which but
when we're getting to talk about a
particular place then that's where the
issue arises and the the JG Ward one has
has always been a bit a bit murky of
recent years Y and that's that's where I
get to the it talks about being a
general reserves uh general policies but
then it also says reserves management
plan and the management plan part comes
under the reserves act which covers all
the reserves which don't have their own
so that's where I look at it and go it
is dealing with reserves so
I mean I think that you made that point
already I mean you've made some really
good points and and Council certainly
listened to it we we've actually all of
the relevant officers here too you know
who are doing that work and they're
listening to so thanks very much for
coming as always and for the research
that you do thank you um always valuable
thank
you okay so if we can do we have Daren
online yet that's just checking to see
if he's still planning to join us Mr T
okay um so we've got the minutes of the
community wellbeing committee meeting
held on the 12th of
December um will somebody move that we
receive those thanks Trish and seconded
by pa um is there any discussion of
those okay well somebody
so all those in favor say I I against
carried
the next minutes are of the district
licensing committee and I might just
leave them until D comes on I know we
can receive and pro for but if that is
on then we'll do it then um that takes
us to the general policies Reserve
management plan on page
so at the last um meeting of this
committee
we spent a lot of time actually going
through this plan in a lot of
detail um and we asked a lot of
questions and we resolved a number of
matters but we
inadvertently um forgot to resolve to
recommend it to council so the point of
bringing this paper back now is not to
open it back up again um is simply
resolve that simple matter so unless
um Chris isn't here
but unless Rex you want to open up for
any reason then I think we'll just um
well summed up and good recollection of
what we didn't do okay Leslie I'll move
this way Evelyn second um are there any
more discussion and if not all those in
favor say I I against carried thank
you Texas to the place strategy
development on page 129 of board
books is there somebody here to speak to
that I think
so
welcome thank you chair uh a Mario Coto
uh good afternoon chair and counselors
um I'm Dr Damen puddle and I am pleased
to be here at ICC as the council's new
play Advocate uh and today presenting
the report on the development that's
beginning on the ICC play
strategy um just to summarize the report
with a couple of key points sport New
Zealand has identified through
International and National research that
the benefits of play are significant uh
and that they contribute to all four
well-beings for local government however
they also recognize that children right
and opportunity to play is under threat
in New Zealand and the Innovative
approaches are necessary to ensure
quality experiences throughout our
cities now and in the future uh and that
is the reason why they're investing in
local government uh via the local play
Advocate Workforce
program a new strategy for play is
necessary to respond uh to this need and
invic Carle has always actually had a
strong uh playground provision uh and we
also know that play occurs at other
Council facilities uh including non
profit and private Enterprises as well
however it's also now well known that
play Can Happen anywhere that children
have time space and permission to do so
and the 2021 play and Southland report
by active Southland uh recommended uh
the importance of exploring play Beyond
play playgrounds for the community and
this requires a strategic council-wide
and indeed city-wide approach um to play
provision the strategy will also set the
guiding principles necessary for the
quality delivery of the Urban play
project uh and will respond to and align
with national gcy agent gu guidelines
strategies and policies as identified an
attachment one that all import uh points
to the importance of play work over
recent years by ICC and active Southland
has built a great Foundation to develop
the strategy and begin delivering play
in a more more holistic manner that
better meets Community need thank you
and happy to answer respon to question
three questions I'll ask the first one
Daman um you're comment right at the
beginning was
that um play was under threat nationally
I mean I'm paraphrasing that exactly
what you said but that was the sense do
you want to fill that out a little bit
what you mean by that yeah so that data
that sport New Zealand speak to talk
about sort of changing societal trends
that impact on the way that children
experience play today compared to how
they used to experience it so changing
uh access to technology and time spent
on those Technologies
uh changing and at times uh often more
stringent uh approaches to health and
safety that may not always be necessary
uh changing uh parenting Trends uh there
are changes to uh built infrastructure
uh and provision of certain types of
facilities and access U to Green Space
and other areas for play so those are
some of the things that they identify as
impacting on children's experiences now
that they may not have actually
experienced uh when we were children do
we have any s so second question um
that's a nationalist suspect worldwide
Trend um but do we have any data on the
situation in inaro or souland so the
2021 Southland uh play Southland report
that I referred to talks to some of that
data it probably doesn't uh present it
in the same way that sport New Zealand
uh is talking about it but um the need
for play in different way ways and
different capacities certainly comes
through quite strongly from that report
okay thank you other questions for Dei
uh so
Grant yeah um it feels bit like a nny
state to be fair um but what I'm
interested in is um I think at a
previous council meeting I asked around
the funding for this role and understand
that your role is funded directly from
central
government but from from here where do
we go in terms of and it's maybe not a
question for yourself it's for one of
the officers so um is is all the work
that you will do fully funded by central
government or do we have to allow some
Opex to fund this role once now that
you're in the
position well I I guess I can't speak to
the the duration of my role as fixed
term for two years um from funding from
sport New Zealand yeah um it's up to
council whether that that continues uh
the point uh I guess guess a key point
of my work is not about creating a whole
lot of new projects but rather how does
play form a component of existing work
how does play actually form an outcome
of existing things that already
occur yeah so secondary sort of point
then you know back to my point around is
that the council's role isn't that
parents role and key givers role I mean
we we have parks and we've got we
abundance of parks and another paper
there's so many spaces that we've got it
inago where
abounding with opportunities for people
to play what why is it the council's
role to get involved in a in a in a role
that should be taken up by the
caregivers and the
parents my response would be that
parents certainly have a role um
undeniably and that's included within
the things that support New Zealand were
talking about don't they have a
responsibility yes um but also Council
does as well in our response to the four
well-beings play as a component in all
of that and that's within the Local
Government Act
the other component is that
play the play What Would I call it
Community I guess whether that's
Scholars Advocates uh researchers Etc
identify that for a child to have a
quality play experience they need the
time the space and the permission to do
those activities and parents play a
component of that but also local
government does as well in terms of what
permissions are given to the public to
use spaces in certain ways as well as
most of the space is owned and managed
by Council yeah so isn't that haven't
you just clarified what our role is it's
just to bide the space and and so and
the right permissions and so the data is
saying that at this stage local
government is not
providing in the way that the community
needs I think actually sorry the crush
you but it also goes to my question that
um rather than generalizations about the
nation or even about the world which you
know the more that we can look aliz it
so that we're actually getting you know
data
and recommendations that are based on
the actual situation on the ground here
um anyway um who have I got next p I
actually um just touching on what K do
just here because I agree with with with
a lot of what you said you made a
good but the other thing as I know we've
got you know you talked about Library
special Palace and schools and and all
those other things and I was thinking
there is no shortage of green space in
this part of the country at all
literally um we we very fortunate I'm
just wondering are you looking more
about how to bring those other um
individual type Play Pieces like schools
and all that together or I was just
trying to get a bit more because I do
have to say you know it's
really up to F families and V and how
they they engage in play which is not
Count's
responsibility but open to um any ideas
and solutions yeah so the strategy we
haven't pre predetermined what the
outcomes of that strategy might look
like um but certainly acknowledging
there hasn't been a Citywide approach to
play and there are individuals in
separated groups that provide different
opportunities that haven't considered
their overlaps and so local government I
believe has a role in potentially
bringing those things together uh in a
more strategic and targeted approach um
that meets Community need um yeah I'm
new to inle but certainly there is an
abundance of of Green Space here but
access to that green space uh is at
times limited um we I've been data
shared with me that there are people in
South City who have never been to Queens
Park and that's not purely based on
Choice okay we we'll keep going CU I
think
everybody's wants to ask a question of
will keep going aing it um yes I think I
was wondering whether some of the
pressure is coming from things
like the push to
intensify the use of land so smaller
allotments houses taking up most of the
space less outdoor space in people's
personal properties to play as opposed
to when I was a child where you could
not only play on your section but you
could play on the street um
you know that we've changed the Dynamics
by making sections smaller Council plays
a part in that is that part of what
you're trying to draw to our attention
that these are the parts that Council
play in absolutely potentially may play
y yeah WID of Roads speeds on roads um
crossing times um for children to play
independently and move through their
neighborhoods they need to be able to do
that safely and easily uh and at times
independently of their parents and if
those spaces aren't safe for them to do
so then they're unlikely to do that and
if you don't have a car then you won't
be driving them to a playground and and
just a
followup whilst we have a lot of Green
Space there's also some pressure on us
to have less um but are the places that
you can see that we
have a Poverty of green space so
therefore the opportunities for people
in some places is less than in
others yes yeah correct um but it's very
expensive to create new Green Space uh
and so that's where having a council and
Citywide approach to figuring out
actually where can play occur beyond
what we've traditionally understood as
prescribed zones uh of activity usually
on Reserve
Land R you're next yeah uh thank you Dr
puddle for bringing through your
recommendations I I also just touch on
what other councils have said play in
New Zealand is under threat but I'd like
to suggest also that family life in New
Zealand is well in trly under threat in
terms of what families AKA through our
children can and can't have access to as
well and I get what you're saying herea
our city with heart we have to provide
services for our community in order for
our community to get ahead and um I
guess take part in these areas of
concern that come up through different
government agencies my question to you
though
is there are multiple issues in every
community in every country that we are
facing even globally with um things like
crime um parents not able to trust the
community that they live in to leave the
kids at the park to play their safety we
have so many variables of concerns that
how does this report um
identify those concerns and how can we
as a council look at yearsas that are
relevant to us under the Local
Government Act in order to
have our play not under threat for our
children so how do we balance that up
because we can only do so
much I think that probably a rhetorical
question
actually difficult for you to answer
that question so I'm going to take
Alex's question next Alex
um honestly I got to say I'm a little
bit disappointed in some of the comments
that have been bouncing around the table
um like we that's some of the comments
are like oh traditional rle is just
pipes and playgrounds like you do you
need to consider that this is far wider
societal well-being and health outcomes
for families if we can strategically
look at the fact that it's not just
parts and playgrounds and reserves and
have an overarching strategy of actually
the participation the access it's like
saying okay we've got a playground but
we won't put any accessible equipment in
it because um you know families should
be responsible for picking up their
children and their children's wheelchair
and putting them in the in the on the
swing and pushing them on the swing it's
the same level of accessibility for that
should be available for All Families to
come and enjoy our part's playgrounds
but not only that would be like saying
we should scrap all the children's
activities that we've got at the library
that's for play
participation like it's it's so much the
outcomes of play is so much wider than
just facilitating physical
infrastructure it's the health outcomes
and the community outcomes that we have
by investing in this as just so
significant I don't I I'm really I'm
really struggling to understand how um
how you C how we how we how this isn't
seen as as to be such a fantastic step
forward for us and I really um yeah I'm
excited that we've got the role and I'm
excited to see um Dr Damian puddle so
it's a good debate actually so we'll
keep going with that so Trish your next
um thank you very much for your
presentation you talk about permission
to use the spaces are you saying are you
looking to use the other places in an
inative way so that children have have
more opportunities to play
differently yes so I guess the prise of
the play strategy that is a given is
looking at play Beyond parks and
playgrounds it's yet to be determined
what that looks like what those outcomes
look like but in the 3 years of my work
in plag leacy for Hamilton City Council
that was absolutely what we were
exploring so you would be excuse me a
second one you'd be looking for places
permission from the council to have play
operating in unusual places potentially
yeah thank you okay I'll check one more
question buddy yeah what do you what do
you think you're going going to be able
to achieve in the in the two years like
the three things that you talked about
um what do you actually want to achieve
in this two first two
years the big thing for this year is
certainly the play strategy itself um
the second is kicking off the urban play
project um and then the third thing um
really is bringing attention to what is
that we're talking about in regards to
what does it mean to do play Beyond
playgrounds uh and and Parks because
it's not well understood um and so my
role uh will be to help um support all
of council and all relevant stuff to
understand what that means in their in
their context of work and influence
okay I said that was the last question
bar but I'm going to take Leslie because
I think she put hand up just at a right
moment thank you Mr Cher I don't know
that mine is so much of of a question as
as in some ways a comment I've
also um listened to some of the comments
around the table and I found some of
them quite interesting from counselors
who were very keen that we incorporated
so many playful elements in their
streetcape development in esand Dawn
Street and because I've heard so many
good comments back about those playful
elements that we took a very conscious
decision to incorporate I'm I suppose I
was a bit surprised to hear a little bit
of push back about um the play strategy
development um and I and it's not so
much a question but my feeling is that
it's a discussion that we would probably
progress better in mid year when we
actually have the further p in front of
us what we've got today is very much an
introduction um and yeah so um it's not
so much a question as a just saying I
think we can have a lot more discussion
when we've got something something more
developed in the play strategy but look
if if we can bring together some of the
elements that we sort of try to
incorporate as playful extras in the
streetcap development into a more more
holistic plan I'm pretty much all for
this going ahead well certainly
for a committee which is called the
community Well Community wellbeing
committee it seems like a pretty
reasonable thing to be discussing look D
Daman I I um this is just about the most
I've seen in terms of contribution from
counselors I know not everybody's
standing up and cheering but everybody's
interested in the subject uh I I think
when we start to when we see
the next report which presumably will
start to get more into here are some
things that you could do Council um it
will become more real for us because you
get that s Continuum between sort of do
nothing or build it and you'll come but
just build it and they'll come and then
you've got I think your area work which
is more about well you need to do a lot
more than that actually counil to
encourage people to come and you make
sure that they can come and you know
those sorts of questions so I'm really
interested in your recommendations I
mean what what I would encourage you the
given you know money is always limited
is to make sure that it's obvious in
your report what your key
recommendations are you know if you can
get it to sort of two or three or four
key recommendations there might be you
know 20 sub recommendations I don't mind
that but if you can get two or three or
four high level recommendations you say
this is going to make a difference then
it's more likely actually to um you know
not only get support of council but
actually get some money from Council you
do it so thanks very much for your
report appreciate it so um we are asked
to receive the report there's no will
somebody move that we receive the report
thank you liely second Trish all those
in favor say I I against
carried
okay so that takes us to the Southland
spaces and places
strategy which is an update on the 2021
strategy Mr chair when we received the
report did we incorporate the other two
recommendations cuz I'm happy to okay
yes so you're moving that we
incorporates all three yes okay and
Trish are you happy with that yes thank
you okay so I'll ask again all those in
favor say I I against carried
mindlessly so that takes us to the
Southland Regional spaces and places
strategy um Rex is somebody going to
present this Caroline and Chris I'll
speak to this they're both on leave um
and as the report take it as read um and
really it's an update of uh a process
that has been has has been taking place
at an officer level over the last 18
months or so across multiple agencies um
including Community funders as well as
local authorities um you'll see from the
recommendations in the report it is
really now uh endorsing the guiding
principle we're asking for the
endorsement of The Guiding principles um
and um supporting of the development for
the next Sports field management plan to
occur this calendar year um and adopting
this and committing to implementing it
as part of our work programs and some of
the questions I've been asked previously
have been around the implementation of
it and I can assure you that the Parks
and Recreation staff are incor have
Incorporated this uh as it stands into
their activity management plans and uh
normal or business as usual work
programs as much as possible going
forward so it's really just seeking that
endorsement and adoption as for those
recommendations i' got a questions and
re I'll ask one first what I found
difficult with this paper was to be able
to identify what the changes were since
2021 you know it's it's it's not
presented in that sort of way where you
can see what those are that made it
actually quite difficult to because the
2021 paper was obviously approved by
Council um we've been asked to approve
an update but when you read it it's not
obvious what the update is so can you at
least comment on I don't want to stop
the process by making that comment but
can you at least comment on how much
change that is in that in that um I'd
have to go back and refer back to the
2021 um strategy um but it it was really
a full review so it was really start
with a clean sheet with which is what
Richard Lindsay consultancy who were
engaged to do the work was undertaking
so is that appropriate then rather than
you see as an update is to see as a a
new document basically well it's yeah
it's adopting the um south regional spes
strategy
202 yeah yeah okay so questions to
R okay edelyn um first of all just me
being n picky under the purpose and
summary it would be really helpful if
the macrons were there as they are in
the attached documents so above the A
and N andah because otherwise it doesn't
make sense
um I'm perhaps assuming and I'm hoping
I'm assuming correctly that this is
taking our strategy and the South and
wide strategy and making them talk to
each other um I looked at the attachment
and the first thing that I saw was W out
on the eastery and thought this is
speaking to me is um not just
traditional um images of Southern places
and
spaces um it's not a power booat and
it's not a Rugby field and I'm really
quite or or jety I'm quite excited this
is the kind of activities I think even
that we were talking about and
and looking at different play
strategies these are the things that our
people could be doing at relatively low
cost and quite close to home um but we
don't talk about it enough and we don't
encourage it enough I don't believe but
anyway that's my soak box um have I have
I brought it
together we approved our plan for the
city this is the South and wide bringing
all the playing fields all the
rationalizations all those conversations
together and if I've if I've worked it
out right then I'm absolutely excited
about this because I think it must have
taken quite a bit of effort on a lot of
people's part to make the different
organizations talk to one another and
bring it all together so thank you for
that I
congratulate um Mr Lindsay good yeah
thanks j a question and a comment
referring to page six of the um paper
137 and the reference around and but to
what Evelyn's talked about around
bringing the region together and how we
provide for
sports historically we haven't played
that well together so i' be interested
in how we're going to be different in
the future um and then um page 153 in
the
appendex um the demograph demographic
breakdown um gives me quite a bit of
concern because we've just previously
had a presentation around play but who
pays and if you look at the trajectory
of that breakdown of where we're heading
demographically we're going to have a
whole lot of old aged
people who don't have a lot of income as
we know how's their Community going to
survive and so I think there's a really
strategic um issue we need to lean into
around Economic Development so we do get
you know the 30s somethings coming to
town and having kids all staying so that
we can have houses that we can charge
rates to we can fund all this stuff but
if you look at that demographic
breakdown where you're going to have a
whole lot of old age pensioners who are
going to be tight for cash and living
from the
government in a lot of instances that
can't afford all the stuff that we're
clocking up so I think we need to take
account of that this year particularly
as we roll out all sorts of different
things around our priorities and
economic development has to be a key
part of how we do anything I mean it's
got so simplications is it's kind of
different subject than we're talking
about but just listen to what you say um
there's no point in having Economic
Development based on labor intensive
Industries because we're not going to
have the labor to satisfy them that's
the reality and and you know and that
really means that when we do look at um
Economic Development we really do want
to be pushing the high tech stuff that's
got you know High productivity but don't
necessarily need a whole lot of Grant
labor because they're just not going to
be there people not going to be willing
to do it Alex you're next yeah
you um Grant you've actually hit the
nail on the head and that this the the
first instance of this was actually put
together and consolidate it
consolidating all of the available
Partners so that the strategy can
actually inform everybody who pays for
anything in the city including Thunders
um Sports New Zealand active Southland
um ilt the trust like literally anybody
who ever pays for any kind of sporting
or Recreation facilities any spaces and
places to be able to understand and have
a an informing framework to understand
where that investment should be best s
spent going forward so everybody is you
know talking to each other they've all
set the boundaries they've all set the P
principles and then they can we can then
and us as I guess the sports Field
Sports Fields strategy is a really good
example of that because we've got 53
Sports Fields how do we know which ones
are going to be the most important ones
if we don't develop a strategy how are
we going to know in future as you say
we've got aging demographics how are we
going to know where our best rate payer
dollar is spent and on which
Fields rate Dollars tax rate pay who
pays the Tex though right this is the
whole whole point sorry how does the
government pay for it they pay for it
through text but if you've got a whole
lot of people that aren't working and
are taking from the Texs are not
creating Economic Development are they
there's no text to be text yeah
absolutely sorry you're right but this
what we are talking about right now is
the spaces in place that's the horse and
cart Theory right we got to get the
horse in front of the cat and the horse
is the economic development but the the
cart is currently carrying so look we're
getting a bit cross table debate going
here which is we've still got the C it's
only
janary so we at the questions to next
stage sorry yeah Rex I would be
interested in my question sort of how we
bring everyone together because you
you're well versed in this so active
Southland was the one that brought
everybody together and um then based on
all of the data and based on all of the
working groups and everything formed
this spases in place a strategy with the
consultant yeah but actually how we phys
going to play together when we say Okay
District sou District Council fund the
stadium more because it's a
regional they get to play there now get
Mye okay um I don't think there's any
other questions I do have one for you
though Rex which um the two cultural
advisers Victor and Cheryl who I'm
embarrassed to see I don't know did they
come by recommendation of maneno or
where was the was that the the process
I'm sure you known so the late Vicor Man
2 um actually worked for um at the time
in our um Social Services um and Sh
hanady currently I think works for Dia
but I'm not sure on what basis she was a
member of this panel but I do know both
people if that's the answer invited
through channels okay thank you so if
there's no other questions then we'll go
back to
the
recommendations I'm happy to move all SE
recommendations Chair say that again
sorry I'm happy to move all sex
recommendations thank you CH and I'm
happy for you to do that if I can find
them
okay to so um will someone second that
recommendation thank you
um is there any more
discussion so all those in favor say I I
I against carried thank you you Mr CH
can go back to councel D and answer
answer your questions outside of the
meeting
yeah yeah know I mean really important
discussion probably this just isn't
quite the right place it meting um okay
that takes us to the D of Park Master
Plan update on page 189 and again I
guess Rex you're going to have to be it
you's GNA oh surprise
Hi C everyone uh thank you chair uh so
the purpose of this report is to
readdress where we're at following the
information gathering
exercise um since it was endorsed to
start moving forward last year we have
put together emerging themes based on
what we've been hearing from the
community what we've been seeing through
the strategies and policies that are
currently out there as well as looking
and doing that due diligence with um
what infrastructures out there the GIS
mapping and those bits and pieces to try
and paint that picture for ourselves
before we start forming uh the draft
master plan
um we'd like to incorporate the emerging
themes in into the ltp consultation um
just to be able to test it with the
community and um get any comments or
feedback before we then form the draft
master plan which would go back to
council um for consideration and um put
that forward then to consult again with
the public for stage one of the the
management plan when that's approved um
so that's the the key points I wanted to
address does anyone have any
questions uh uh have one
um where Mich Michael gathers other
names for other questions but I have one
so um I I promise there a a question at
the end of this right so got a little
speech at the beginning so I I I go to
Donovan Park regularly with my dog and
by the way I like the geese and the
Ducks um I mean I would mind the
barricades to protect Donovan Park but
what I think of a Donovan Park and I
suspect what most people think of as
Donovan Park is the area with a pond and
you walk through with the toilets and
you know you go up through there but
that would be less than a third I think
of the area of the park wouldn't it
correct the 79 hectares is mainly made
up of the farm the farm owned by the
city and operated by the city just to
keep the grass short we run sheep on it
I think
BR so my question is about how when we
go and ask people about the future of
Donovan Park and their vision for that
um how they get the context of the
question so just taking that a little
further so if I went to a group and said
um how do you feel about using a part of
Donovan park for commercial purposes
then I would expect that maybe everybody
would say no right if in the other hand
I go to a group and a see um the city
population is increasing
significantly um disproportionately as
older people within a few years there'll
be at least a thousand more over 70s in
Inver cargo than there are at the moment
um at the moment there's no place for
them to live um you know we're
considering Donovan part part of Donovan
the Western end of Donovan Park which is
Terra incognit as far as people nobody's
ever seen it right right the Western end
of Donovan Park we're considering that
as maybe a suitable site to put um maybe
a retirement village or something of
that sort it would house maybe
500 if it was 30 hectares it would house
about 500 people of the Thousand
increasing and if you put if you put it
like that suddenly the the group that
says L against you know suddenly people
I think far more people say well
actually that says better better to have
Elder housing than sheep grazing right I
think a lot of people would feel that
way so getting back to my question is
about when we go to groups and speak to
them whether we are explaining the
context in that sort of way the other
question I would asking part of the same
question is whether given that context
when we do go and talk to groups do we
talk to people like age concern gr power
you know those sorts of people are going
to have that context rather than you
know the equestrian group of the you
know P that who want to use it for the
um you know for the
training and if I take the if I take the
peret one because it's one I can speak
to personally any pical do we're
surrounded by padic there's a thousand
places and around in cargo they could do
that work peret could do that work
there's no strategic C for their point
of view so anyway coming back to the
question which is really about how do we
how do we make sure that people in
answering the question have the context
that allows we give a an informed answer
cool told you there was a speech
attached no and and and two two
questions I think yeah so how do we put
the message across to to get that
feedback so um we had a mixed range of
Engagement um to to get the feedback
through are you specifically wanting to
know about disposal though because we um
we wanted to make sure that when we went
out with regards to finding out what
people wanted for the future of Park um
we tried to make those questions as
broad as possible while also noting that
there is an area um for potential
alternative land use which wasn't be to
be defined straight away but through
conversations with the community we've
been able to um flesh that out that this
is a a space that um is that council is
interested in for um a variety of of
uses that could that could include that
so um from a Parx and R perspective we
follow the reserve reses act to get as
far as the removing Reserve status over
a piece that we would see a surplus and
then down the track it would then be how
Council would like to use that land in
the future whether it be um for anything
um I do notice that there's only 12% of
respondents who are dead against the
idea of building anything there but
again um I don't want to repeat myself
it's just about making sure people have
the context so they can respond
appropriately Trisha you on the sorry I
beg your pardon Leslie first thank you
uh k my questions a little bit more
detailed so I'll refer to page 196 of
our agenda so it's under the maximizing
activation of Donovan Park
l so I'll read it out to you because it
might make it simpler um in the initial
Parks land disposal options paper 37
hectares of land was POS was proposed
for reconsideration towards revocation
of the reserves status under the
ACT later in that paragraph it
says um when considering this
reorganization of land there is a
potential for 5 to 10 hectares of the
park to be considered for alternative
land use so just for my
clarity are
we going
to propose or put out a much L parcel
than the original intention so
originally we were looking at 37
hectares for the reserve status
potentially be
revoked are we now at the stage where
we're saying are from the speedback it's
only 5 to 10 hectares that we would look
at proposing revocation on or are we
still
saying it's debatable I'm just not
absolutely clear have we have we greatly
reduced the hectares we originally
talked
about what we've been hearing and um
seeing is that there are a lot more um
the ideas that have been coming through
for use of Donovan Park um is taking up
a lot of that space that would have been
alternative land use um things like
events and that sort of stuff um are
coming through a lot stronger um there
is still appetite for um an area of land
it might not been as as large as what we
originally anticipated purely because of
master plan process we've been able to
identify other ideas that have been
coming through from the community that
they would like to use this space for
further to Leslie's question I thought
when I read that part that there was a I
was a little bit concerned that there
was an element of predetermination in
that um you know we're quoting numbers
for how much may be available we just
about to go to you know public
submission and the long-term plan so I
think we have to be a bit careful I
think the other thing that we have to be
careful of is um
but if the amount of land is subscale it
may be simply impossible to do anything
very much with her anyway Lesley you
again you want to thank you well it was
it was just supplementary Mr chair and
and because of Casey's answer it's
probably a suggestion to the committee
that that's a very significant heer
reduction yeah that we might want to
Workshop quite intensively as a Council
yeah um because that is a
remarkably different place than we have
talked about in the last workshops we
had on the point and it just seems to me
if we're talking about a maximum of 10
hectares where we were looking
previously at
37 agree and it go again it's a matter
of who who determines the priorities to
what extent so so who's accountable for
thinking about the number of elderly
people where they're going to live
that's one in we need to worksh is Mr
Che it's a dramatically different um
size of space that we're talking about
and the earlier discussion was looking
at something quite different from this
feedback which changes the picture
significant quite quite substantially so
I think that's a really good idea do we
need a resolution on that or can
managing just nod to that and we so
we've going to nod sorry Michel uh
through yourself CH I'd just like to
reverse that statement of um Council can
I'm just in looking at that and say
basically as part of this process you
have identified there's a need from the
community for somewhere between 27 to 32
hectares to perform the services that
they um currently perform on on that
site or desire to perform on on that
particular site um Council will need to
consider the need and of of the
community in relation to that and
whether there's another place that that
could be serviced as well as part of
that um equation so that would need to
come forward as part of that as a
discussion point to council it's not
necessarily saying that um it's not 37
or council could decide yes um they do
want to allocate that and you end up
with 10 hectares available but from my
perspective that has not come through to
council yet and relation to that the
communities voiced the their need and
requirement as part of that process and
Council will need to go through that how
they they do or don't service that need
so Michael does are you agreeing M
that's appropriate to Workshop it
through
Council um I I will look to my Parks
team in relation to that um from a
findings perspective but I think that um
is something they'll need to consider
whether it's a workshop or whether it's
a report I need to look for their
guidance in relation to how they want to
approach that
true yeah this is the start of a process
or that has already started but we're
we're still very much in the um early
stages of it and part of the next
development phase
includes um consultation with a link to
the ltp um which is Incorporated in here
subsequent to that there will be further
engagement that need will need to come
back as Council so is to discuss around
that with the with the council um before
before we get the final draft which is
proposed to go out uh for for for
consideration uh in March April yeah
yeah so there's a lot of work to still
happen in that Eng development even I
mean that's just initial response to
some of that in very early feedback um
but yeah the council needs will be
brought in as part of those
conversations all the way through okay
and
whether it's I I think probably a good
Workshop it will be a good Workshop
Topic in in that March April period
because it does have to there is a need
isn't there to balance the need um and
the priority of different things some of
which are actually nothing to do with
play I'm using that word or nothing to
do with immunity um you know something
like the need to provide housing for
elderly people given the change in the
demographics and the change in the
population you know how does that come
in how does that get considered
so I think okay there's work which um
Council officers have to do but I think
it would be really good to bring that
back here at some point for ideally a
workshop I
think okay I have um
Grant yeah thanks to um I think really
good point you've made there Leslie and
also I really endorse the comments
you've made um Tom around you know how
we ask that question through this
process is really really important
because you know in my mind it is a
um well tradeoff is the word that's
floating around on my head I'm not sure
that's the right word but you know we
have to make some compromises um where
you know if you look at the plan we're
laying out in the in the long-term plan
you know we need Capital coming into the
program to be able to provide some cool
services and that's a reality so I think
that's really important about how we ask
the question how we inform the public to
Rodney's point to make sure they fully
understand the why I think that's a
really important piece of the process
and I'm a big fan of having a map which
I've made a point to Rex on
um and and then I think Michael you
referenced um 32
hectares there's people there that think
they need 32
hectares um I'd be interested in what
activity that is that needs 32 hectares
that's a big big
area um so can I just ch just reinforce
that the purpose of this report is to
really update you on the process and the
progress the debate and the discussion
around what's in that master plan and
how is over the next three month period
I think though sorry Rex I think though
it does go process you know the question
I was asking about you know who gets
consulted you know are they are they
actually made aware of the the the the
logic behind it are we talking to people
like you know age concern grare about
the need for elderly housing I mean that
so it does go processes not only but
outcome yeah equally sorry for May you
know I think we've got to be careful of
statements around on page s of 11 high
level of public engagement 200 out of
21,000 rate payers or 55,000 people
that's not a high level of Engagement
you know that's a small sample of the
population
sharing their view so I think we've got
to be cautious around that and then the
statement on page n of 11 or 197 aboard
box around um the future focus of um
focused economy delivering through
Innovation and partnership I struggle to
see how the statement under how the
master plan will deliver that is is
economic has an economic
impact so leave it as a rhetorical
question Grant and we'll keep going with
the trick you are next oh my questions
really is just I want us to be very
clear that we what everyone has said is
what we actually want um I've heard that
Donovan Park from many people I don't
know how many many years not not what
you've got obviously but people don't
understand what Donovan Park is they
think Donovan Park is what Tom described
and they don't know and I think we're
getting wrong information we could be
getting wrong information about what
they perceive as Donovan Park so it's
very important that they get the picture
of why but they also understand what
part and um I think some you might have
been you Tom mentioned about the fact is
it viable in the part that we're left
with so they're really really important
questions um if if this is going to be
an effective piece of
consultation thank you yeah
yes um thank you Mr chair
um casy on page 194 book books which I'm
not sure what page it is of your report
but it talks about highly productive
land and I'm hacking back to what the
chair said when he was talking
about the Sheep on the farm it's only
there to keep grass down now it's a bit
more than that it's the obligation that
we made when we bought the land off the
off the Donovan Faro but the importance
to the city of this piece of land is
becoming actually in terms of the farm
is increasing in importance because we
have only I think three Urban Farms left
and this might become the only one
within a very short space of time so
where do City young people actually see
Livestock on a real working farm on
productive land which is meant to be
used for this purpose so if we're going
to put housing on class two
land what have we
sacrificed and what other opportunities
and and sorry but actually my mind did
go back to play because there seems to
be a theme that's going through
everything that's coming today and that
is that not everything is about hardened
surfaces not everything is about houses
even though I think housing is vitally
important not everything is about
infrastructure to make it easier to get
to work some of it is about the quality
of life we live in the city that in
which we live and the experiences that
we have as a community within this city
um if we take
away for example the opportunity for
sheep to gra and for people to see them
grazing are we actually taking away an
element of what actually is intrinsic to
this
country postc colonially of how the land
has been used and how people have
interacted with that land and are we
actually taking away from the future
citizens of this city an opportunity to
see how this country the economy of the
post 1840 economy actually grow because
this is it in a nutshell within the city
boundary now now I'm not saying that
there may not be parts that may be
considered to be suus but can I just say
that when we first started talking about
selling off Don Donovan Park not that I
was one that was s selling Donovan
park it wasn't elderly housing that we
were talking about it was housing for
people who don't want to live south of
tweet street so let's be real about this
if elderly housing is what ends up on
the the portion that we have that could
very well be um my Optimum goal yeah did
can I can I and so I mean kassie what is
the implications for us if we take the
urban farm out if we take this highly
productive land out and we expand the
city where where is where is our city
with
heart can we leave it as a rhetorical
question we can um but I mean you know
your points very well made I mean the
only the only comment I would make
Evelyn was I was I was involved right at
the beginning of this with noes Donovan
Park and Mer as a possible site and and
I can assure you certainly at the
beginning whether it drifted I'm not
sure but certainly at the beginning it
was elderly housing that was the
target I have um Alex and then
rangy that's me um hey look I was just
going to say that I I really do agree
with um your speech at the beginning
there at Tom I think what people's
perception of Donovan Park is and what
it actually is is um really
quite disconnected um another thing I
guess I just wanted to talk about is
that I know we've got a lot of plans and
places and spaces and um strategies and
that underway and obviously the Donovan
Park master plan is one of those but I
think it's a really good example of how
we've gone to you know a substantial
amount not a lot but a substantial
amount of um um residents to ask them
what what they think that that piece
that that they know of Donovan Park I
guess so the I'm talking about like I
guess the pond area and that kind of
thing could be utilized or like thinking
outside of the box what do they want to
see for the future of that right and it
doesn't always necessarily have to be
expensive which comes to the point that
Grant made earlier that we've got all
these plans and strategies but how are
we actually going to pay for them when
we've got an aging populace and an
example of that and thinking outside of
the box and seeing some new emerging
Trends um that i' really like to give
that's not particularly expensive is
things like disc golf we already had
Queens Park and the inner city all we
needed was a bunch of baskets and we're
looking at other places that we can put
that and it didn't cost us a lot to
implement but what it did was give
permission for people to play in a
different way it's things that we've
heard in um in the youth Council um
engagement piece that we had with um
around this um Donovan Park master plan
heard somebody say say why don't they
put in a Warf on the pond so that people
can use their model boats you know like
it's really lowcost ideas out of the box
that could actually just give people
permission to play in a different way
that adds to community heart and
Community well-being it's those kinds of
initiatives that me personally I think I
would love to see come out of that play
strategy development and all sorts of
places and spaces and playgrounds and
whatever it is that um we can facilitate
right across the city um and yeah I
guess that's that's my two seconds of
rant I just really hope that we can see
some of those outcomes that we've seen
in this and as this one's further along
than the the play strategy is that you
hope you can see some of those
synchronicities thank you Alex rang is's
last uh thank you chair look my
questions around seeking
Clarity on the paragraph that um talks
about the conditions the Donovan family
um placed on on the sale now reading it
it it it just gets a bit wobbly in the
sense that uh the request where they
were not wanting encroachment of the
city
um seems to be until the
1980s and then it comments there's been
an appropriate passing of time since
then to develop a master plan
now it like I don't need to enough
answer now but is it possible that as
elected members we can see the official
documentation that records this request
that records the uh subsequent
minutes and uh for us to look at that
and and gain our own uh viewpoints and
maybe even seek uh peer review legal
yeah I S about that as well than FR Rex
wants to yeah thank you coun P it's
exactly a request I've asked of the
staff myself
uh to seek clarification and make sure
we're watertight in what some of that
information historically allows us or
doesn't allow us so I've asked for
exactly that as well and we'll share
that back with elected members so so
that exact information I don't
necessarily need a legal opinion I just
want to see the information y same yeah
okay thank you thank you before we well
I'm going to ask Steve actually comment
on this because you've sat and listen
very carefully Steve what's your
thoughts I think two points around
clarification are what we're what we're
asking and the feedback we're seeking
back from the public is really important
I think there's a massive
miscommunication misunderstanding around
Donovan Park and I think without leading
too much into those future plans really
clarifying in the consultation process
what Donovan Park is and and I think who
we're speaking to around those future
possibilities is so key because you can
just completely M up a miss an
opportunity here to get it right um
you know for for the future of our
community and I think yeah I think
that's probably when reading this I was
slightly concerned around the drop of
hicar uh when reading the agenda as well
and getting clarification around that
that seemed quite black and white around
but I understand it were just the at the
beginning of the process but yeah it's a
really
key um piece that we're potentially
working on here and I think
clarification on a few things is is is
really important who we're speaking to
and what Donovan Park is and those
parameters I think is key thank you so
look we've got three recommendations um
on page
189 uh that we reive the
report that we confirm the key
themes um and that we confirm that
Council officers will finalize the
master plan I don't know whether do we
need to add um an action there to uh
bring back a those recommendations to
Workshop would that be appropriate Les
actually include that as a a further
recommendation it would be good to have
it recorded Mr chair I think because it
is significantly important step that I
think all the councilors are saying is
important to us so I mean I think the
message is that councel are extremely
interested in this subject and we really
like to be involved rather than simply
see the end output we want to be
involved in the in the process and the
way through so if that can be recorded
as a another recommendation four or
something then we
can go I've get Michael furiously
wordsmithing it so we
speak Mr G logically should it go
before should three become four and
in comes
in
I keep forgetting it's in front of me I
keep spinning around to
look
EAS
gete see
me happy for comments there checking you
spell
oh any typos will be of course rectified
well it was good to rectifi it's not
just about
theuse the whole master and the master
plan
process so do you want to change the
wording of three then right so
you right
Master there also what we can do and
what we can't do depending on the
Donovan fact uh I know that state you
know what the use of that land is for so
for me really important as well that
would be included in
a that R because I mean we should
remember that the decisions around this
issue have got implications for the
longterm plan because the ltp makes
assumptions which have significant
impact on rates in out of years based on
the Assumption that's been made so far
so it's a you know pretty critical
decision that we made would have you
know substantial impact on rates if we
decided to you know reduce the land
available to 5 hectares or
something okay we got it up is everybody
happy with the wording as it's there at
the
moment will somebody move all of those
thanks Trish with somay second thanks
Evelyn all um any further discussion and
if not all those in favor say I I
against carried thank you yeah thank
you
okay okay so um just before we do the
activities report we'll go back to the
item five in the agenda the minutes of
the district licensing committee
unfortunately Dan hasn't been able to
join us he he did warn me that he may
not be able to get a Wi-Fi connection so
that's what's happened so will somebody
move that we receive those Prof former
um thank you liely and seconded by
Evelyn um all those in favor say I I
against carried thank you so that takes
us to the activities
report which is in whose name the group
managers everybody who's going to
present this
one I suppose Mr G we can take it as red
and answer any questions okay are there
any questions
then Rex is going to be the recipient of
those
questions bu seems to be a huge number
of um like the uh parking complaints
gone up from 59 to
85 thinking what what is the reason for
that
same uh through your chair this has been
an ongoing Trend over the year where
we've noticed uh comparing the the
current month with the same month for
the previous year that that has
significant increase the majority of
this uh relates to RFS in the suburbs
where uh essentially people are not
happy with what they would consider to
be abandoned vehicles in the suburbs or
people parking over driveways over
yellow lines those sorts of things and
this is a continu so can you just I mean
I think we asked us question question a
previous meeting and I just forget the
answer so defin parking Complaint Form
is it's not a case of somebody
complaining that they should not have
got a ticket but we're ticketed no no uh
we call those parking disputes so that's
where they've receiv received an
infringement and they're disputing that
infringement a parking complaint is
where an RFS has been lodged where
somebody is complaining about um a
potentially abandoned vehicle uh where
the vehicle might be parked um over a
driveway um
in a causing a safety issue yellow lines
Etc um and bus stops those sorts of
things they sometimes result in an
infringement could I ask and I hate
asking this sort of question because I
know it just increases exponentially the
reports but on a one off basis it'd be
very useful maybe at the next well being
committed actually see a breakdown of
how what those complaints are um just in
a simple list so for example if it was
30 and 29 of them were Vehicles
abandoned that the Beach let's just
suppose I think that would tell a story
in a way that maybe we don't quite get
at the moment from the data I mean I say
and a one-off basis I'm suggesting that
we get you know an ongoing report
that's okay any other questions Grant
yeah just two one with page 202 just
with the limb reporting days slipping
back from sort of an average around five
to sort of seven or eight and that's a
critical piece of Engagement we have
with um you know lawyers and people in
the town that are doing business is
there any reason why that's gone back by
three odd
days I came in through that halfway cuz
I was busy writing notes about the last
comment so that's to do with limbs yeah
what what why is it um the days to get a
limb gone back from 5 days to 8 days
increased so it's more likely to be
because we've actually um stopped doing
five-day limbs they were too difficult
to service um generally we're around 5
days anyway to get them
out but doesn't it say we're actually
over
that so yeah I'd probably have to go and
speak to the team to get a bit more
information on that I do know that we've
changed the 5day limb service and
removed I suppose my Global question is
how's our level of Serv deliver for
limbs is it dropping not as far as I'm
aware it's actually um increased over
the course of 2023 you'll assure us that
it's
not and then um 210 around pie and
animals um on my daily morning walk um
with my dog um I see a heck of a lot of
rabbits in Queens Park and I've thought
about how I could rate them but I can't
so I think they should be exterminated
um they probably think the same about
you yeah they probably do in fact I've
asked them and they have said that to
them um so yeah it is a concern
obviously and we've just planted a lot
of new Young trees um in there and um
you know it'll be a waste of investment
if we don't control the pie in there and
equally out at um fosbender
Park um there's a bit of G in that
creeping in in some of those areas in
broom and I just wonder what a plan
around nipping in the bud person that's
dealt with gors and a lot of farmers
have we'll say it's a second mortgage if
you let it get away um so it's probably
easy to deal with it now as opposed to
wait till it becomes a problem so just
interested in those two
points okay so let those points why
thanks Grant you made the point Ria um I
just some seing some clarification we
got two questions but the first one is
about the um car complaints parking
complaints would that include vehicles
that have been in crashes and their
vehicles half on the road and half off
the road on Council land like in Gara
Street
recently was at
Weeks
crash sorry uh the police
um usually deal with those although we
do sometimes end receiving complaints
about them we follow those up with the
owner if the if we can identify the
owner details from the vehicle often
it's a situation where they um are
waiting for their insurance company to
remove the vehicle if it takes longer
that can usually mean that there's maybe
not Insurance involved or there's other
difficulties but it is up to the owner
to organize the vehicle to be removed so
we're quite happy for that vehicle or
other vehicles to remain on Council land
for up to what time as you like a if we
can't identify the owner then it will be
there's a stickering process but I can't
recall the full details to be able to
explain that sorry no that's okay I just
I noted that recently I'd seen that
happen on a few occasions um over the
last few months um and I thought maybe
come underneath it but my other question
I'm not sure if it's to you but it's to
the parks team bringing up what Grant's
talking about um I to go through Queens
Park every day have noticed the rabbits
in there wonder if the accumulation of
more baby rabbits and being in there is
the fact that there's so many trees that
are felt and sitting there um that you
see all the rabbits con congregating in
there um but I'm wondering like do we
have a time frame of when those trees
that have fallen down me I know we've
asked this question before of Queens
Park with the trees that fall over
through haes and through the um Queens
Park team um but having been there and
seeing all the um particular potential
hazards in the park with the Trees of
children surely we're going to get those
trees up quicker are we
not well with Caroline not here I don't
know if we get any comment on it but
it's unfortunately there's
nobody is it a question that we could
put forward and get an answer back for
yeah I think I mean I think I suspect it
will become health and safety problem
well you can check that away R can't you
and you can respond I mean I think it'd
be useful to respond I suggest you just
fli me email yeah sure now are there any
other questions on the activities
report I don't have any other names so
will somebody move that we receive the
report thanks Leslie and seconded by
Alex um any other discussion those in
favor say I I I against carried thank
you and I think that disposes of all of
the business of the meeting meeting Mr
chair thank you so um will'll close the
meeting at that point and um thank you
to everybody who joined us in live
stream um and good night to you
cheers